I am honored and humbled to have been
chosen by the Conservative Party to
become its leader I would like to pay
tribute to the other candidates during
the election campaign and I would like
to pay tribute to Andrea LED 'some for
the dignity that she has shown today
I would also I would also like to pay
tribute to David Cameron for the
leadership the TV show during during
this campaign my case has been based on
three things first the need for strong
proven leadership to steer us through
what will be difficult and uncertain
economic and political times the need of
course to negotiate the best deal for
Britain in leaving the EU and to forge a
new role for ourselves in the world
brexit means brexit and we are going to
make a success of it
second we need to unite our country and
third we need a strong new positive
vision for the future of our country a
vision of a country that works not for
the privileged view but that works for
every one of us because we're going to
give people more control over their
lives and that's how together we will
build a better Britain thank you